if you've been following my videos for
the last couple of weeks you'll know
that I am at Disneyworld it's not that
responsibly or anything it is just where
I happen to be on holiday now I've been
avoiding Disney trivia because you know
it's a little bit boring it for a while
but there is something that my cameraman
for for the week done W told me that
that I didn't really believe at first
but he assures me it's true I've looked
it up uh which is well Dan where are we
currently standing we're at the Reedy
Creek Improvement District it's Walt
Disney World's own private municipality
yeah essentially Disney World has
private cities granted to them by the
state of Florida because they lobbied a
long time ago when they were buying all
the land here and buying this space they
have all sorts of powers they apply for
planning permission from themselves they
have the ability to build all sorts of
things to be immune from laws of the
neighboring areas that they would
otherwise be beholden to not only that
they have eminent domain as well which
means they can seize small amounts of
land from around their borders of their
own municipality if they need it for out
for the public good and the starving
thing is this Dan what do they
technically have permission to build
they have planning permission from
themselves to build their own nuclear
power station it's in the legislation
from the 1960s till now that's because
way back when they were actually
planning to build a proper city here and
while they've never actually built that
nuke plant they have a small oil fire
plant somewhere on property um they had
their own runway briefly they had all
sorts of hills gonna be a massive city
here and then Walt Disney died in what
we are left with is the experimental
prototype community of tomorrow or Epcot
but you never know one day there might
well be a nuclear power plant here that
is something you might not have known